all right everyone in the back can hear
me I like my mic song okay cool so yeah
this is graph QL my name is Dustin this
talk was originally titled graph QL the
good parts and that's just me being lazy
and uncreate 'iv really it's graph QL
most of the parts so really what I want
to do is I'll start with introduction to
some of the foundational concepts of
graph QL the kind of bits and pieces
that make graph QL so enticing and from
this foundational perspective we'll
construct the argument for why graph QL
matters why graph QL Suite cetera et
cetera what kind of segue into
integration pieces so given you know
this cool concept of graph QL how do we
integrate it with our existing api's our
existing databases are existing rest
back-end
you name it we'll do some brief stuff on
some integration with client-side
libraries using things like Apollo and
then at the end you know time permitting
which I hope I hope we have I'll do some
live coding god save me and I also have
some a few demos at the end too so with
that said Who am I my name is Dustin I
am known for weird pictures and meetups
that was in this listening and every
time I see it it makes me laugh so when
I'm not looking weird and meetup photos
I'm a front-end developer I work for a
company called object partners we just
got voted number one of our size of
Omaha so that's kind of cool
so if you're interested in hearing more
about that about me about JavaScript
you name it come talk to me after at
this bjs I will certainly be there
having a beer so yeah that's that's that
and so I'll start this talk with two
caveats number one Facebook driven
development is a thing
there's react there's react native
there's jest and then there's of course
graph QL and a lot of people you know
aren't super sold on this you know
there's a lot of hype behind a lot of
these you know you might like your
current stack be it ember angular you
know you name it and you don't have to
use all this hot trendy new things I'd
like to think that graph QL is a little
bit different not that reactor magnate
image that aren't great but if you're of
the camp that doesn't want to follow
these hype you know these trends I think
graph QL is more than this I think graph
QL is kind of
transformational and kind of like kind
of like a new shift for how we can
design api's and how we can design
backends so kind of stomach that for
this talk hopefully I'll persuade you
that is not just FDD and there's some
actual validity to this graph QL stuff
second caveat is that I rescue ler I
quoted breast killer in my description
which is a quote of someone else I don't
think that myself so no no it is not
and also chill that's a quote
I don't I don't think that and this talk
is not intended at all to say it I graph
QL is ending rest I think they're both
great technologies and as some of these
slides will show I think that graph QL
enhances rest so this talk is not about
how graph QL is killing rest it's really
centered on the idea of but maybe so
maybe it's not killing rest but maybe
introducing graph QL into your stack can
do some really solid things and can lead
to some really good benefits things like
less payloads that do your client a
cleaner API cleaner documentation all
while if you want to utilizing your
existing restful back-end so that this
talk were accurately titled it would be
graph QL most of the stuff rest is not
dead but maybe we can do better and so
this is what this talk is about
so to begin describing graph QL we need
to talk about what it actually is
so these are the foundational pieces the
kind of like I said earlier bits that
make graph QL so enticing so the very
first thing that graph QL is it's a
query language and so first let's talk
about our existing data structure I'm
using typescript here is that font
readable on the back hopefully sweet
that's great so the typescript we're
defining that our restful api will
return a user in some fashion and a user
is composed of a name which is a string
an age an age which is a number a title
which is a string and a department which
is also a string so just kind of keep
this as a mental model for what a user
is when we're talking about some of the
next stuff so this is our first taste of
graph QL on the top left we have our
graph QL query
and so this is basically kind of think
of it like a function that's injected
with query variables and then these
query variables are then passed to our
actual graph QL query so this is the
actual query this is basically a
function we're calling to kind of make
this dynamic and then pass query
variables on demand and so what graph QL
really is or at least the query language
it basically looks kind of like JSON
with functions these are copies solvers
we'll get into that in a little bit and
basically they take arguments or options
and you specify the type so I'm saying
here that I want to get a user by it by
an ID ID is of type integer a number and
I will make some requests I'll resolve
this data somehow and I'll resolve a
user type and so like we saw earlier a
user was defined of age name title
description but for this particular view
I might not need just our yeah name
title whatever the other category was
and I might only need three of them and
so I'm just pulling exactly what I need
and when I play this query back you can
see that the structure you get the
result is JSON and it directly ties to
the structure that we requested so we
kind of used this JSON like query syntax
and got back JSON so it's pretty clear
user dot age maps directly to age
username wrap maps to user dot name on
the left and that's kind of one of the
big benefits of graph QL is this query
language where you can pluck only what
you need you don't need to pull down the
entire user object even if you're only
using one or two fields and then down
the road you can change it you know if I
don't want that age and that title I can
just do plug this name field here I'm
using an alias so in graphic QL that's
denoted with this little : so I'm
basically saying I want the name as
specified in user but I want it and my
JSON has user name so we make this
request when we get back our expected
structure and shape and so I think many
of you are probably jumping the gun well
this is not really transformative I
could do this in rest with some type of
like CSV like structure where I hit a
restful resource I specify my ID I want
my user and then I just pull the name
age and title or just the name fields
and I agree you know that's actually not
that bad this is all that graphic you
all did this kind of single dimensional
one layer nested data it's not really
replacing rest is not really that much
better we could certainly go with that
structure it I'd be pretty okay with
that but wait you know there's there's
more to this so let's take a look at
another query so let's say down the road
that our view needs to also show a
manager and we want the same type of
fields that we get from a user on this
manager so a manager is a user I'm just
a special special kind of class and they
have the same properties on user so we
want where we are requesting page name
and title and similarly we're also
requesting our kind of nested manager so
I'm getting this user's manager and I'm
pulling age name and title from my
manager as well I can play this query
back and of course I get my expected
shape I get tim-tom a--they the boss man
is 100 somehow so yeah this is a kind of
like a deeply nested query and so I
don't really know how I'd do this with
rest I'm sure someone's really excited
right now to tell me about some library
they have in Java or groovy or back-end
stuff I'm not as good at but I think
graph QL query language makes this
really simple and it kind of directly
ties in some of the next people talk
about using resolvers and kind of doing
this in a really clean clear way getting
a lot of benefits along the way so
queries are the are in crud so let's
talk about the cut the CU d and graph QL
the cut is a mutation and so a mutation
is pretty similar to a query so what it
look like is it is a name of a mutation
a mutation can accept optional arguments
and then a mutation returns optionally
some structure and so for instance if I
want to create a review I'm going to
actually you know send like a post I'm
going to create this review object the
arguments this this mutation accepts are
episode which is a string a review which
is a nested JSON structure so a review
contains stars which is a number
commentary which is a string we run this
and we get back our expected shape so
data dot create review then they get
back stars and commentary it's not super
useful to get back exactly what you
passed in so what I've seen a lot here
is that you get something new that was
kind of created for you and our examples
at the end you get back in an ID field
so something that's kind of generated on
the server that you want to pull back
and use into your UI so now and so
obviously mutation can create a resource
I can trade a resource and you can
delete a resource depending on what you
use and they resolve it which we'll talk
about in a second yeah do the slide
again okay so yeah so I think we'll get
more into this on the in the live coding
but yeah so a mutation is basically
think of it like a function call this
function call is triggering some update
to a database to your restful back-end
it can be kind of anything it just needs
to return something that has the
property stars and commentary so you can
think of a resolver which we'll get to
good okay so graph QL is also a type
system so I know what you're thinking oh
man another type system there's flow and
there's typescript and you know now I
need to know a graph QL type system and
that sort of empathize I just kind of
slightly weird that it's just slightly
different it's kind of looks like
typescript a little bit so here we're
defining our user which we saw earlier a
similar variant we're defining a number
of fields and a number of types so a
user is composed of basically JSON that
looks like ID which is a special graph
QL is on call the ID name which is a
string age and int title of string and
then manager which is a user and you'll
note here the
exclamation point so those exclamation
point means non nullable basically it
means that when I return something that
is of type user it has to have all of
these fields and a user is knowable so
when I make a query or mutation that
returns a user I might not get back a
manager everything else I'm always
expected to return given something that
returns a user
no but IDs work really well with like
caching but you know I don't think you
have to have an ID at all but it does
help things especially when you get into
things like Apollo
it helps caching a lot a lot better so I
said been my experience graph QL is a
schema and so a schema is basically a
composition of a number of types
basically your data model so if it's a
restful back-end you might have swagger
or something and basically you want to
encapsulate that with the graph QL
schema and so what a schema does is it
kind of takes these types and it wires
it up so that graph QL can then expose
this API so here we have our previous
user and now we see our first taste of a
graph QL query so it's just like a user
it's a type and again this kind of looks
you know like a function call because
that's really what it would be doing
when we get to the next section on
resolvers this this function call takes
arguments and so I'm calling this
argument limit limit is of type int and
it'll always return an array which is
not knowable of type users so basically
this means that when I query for users I
need to send a limit and from graph QL
and it'll return zero or more users it
will always return an array and then we
wire it all up with this schema and so
schema takes queries and mutations so
query of type query in the live examples
at the end I'll show a mutation but this
is an example of a graph QL schema I
will note here and I explain it
more depth in a second this is using
something called graph QL tools which is
a library from Apollo that I think makes
stitching this up and wiring this up a
little bit easier but there are other
ways to do it than writing it this way
there's like more JavaScript the API
that the actual graph qlj s module
exposes but I think this is a little bit
cleaner so it's a means to resolve data
so up to this point we've kind of said
well here is what our API is but we
haven't really injected this API with
data we haven't made this API live and
so how that works in graph QL is via a
concept of resolvers so this is slightly
challenging to explain but basically
every key and this object at the root
level at the first level refers to a
type so query is referring to our query
in the previous example you know query
is here and so the fields inside are
children of that that main type or that
or in this case the query so to resolve
users the kind of path is a JavaScript
object query with a sub key of users
I'll talk on the next slide about what
this what these function arguments are
these root args etc but for now
basically each one of these resolvers
needs to return a promise that resolves
to data or it needs to return that data
directly so you know if you didn't have
an API and just wanted to like mock it
out you could just as easily return like
an array of user objects here without
actually making a request to your server
so it's really easy way to mock stuff
out next so we have that user type and
when we request a manager it'll call
graph QL we'll call this manager
function and it'll make a separate
request so basically because a manager
is a separate kind of user it's not
exposed when I query for users I need I
need to give graph QL a hint that when I
see this manager field how do I actually
resolve this to a user and so the API is
basically where same as any other
resolver we're returning a func
returning a promise or some kind of like
simple value that maps to what we're
requesting so let's get into these
arguments and what each of them mean all
right so resolvers in depth so query and
mutation are kind of special the first
argument is basically the current value
of what you're resolving and so because
query doesn't really the value of the
parent and so because query doesn't
really have anything special the root
here is basically undefined it's not
super useful part is basically the an
object of arguments that I've sent to
this graph QL query so earlier I think I
showed limit and so args would be a
JavaScript object with limit defined as
like a number context I want to mention
I don't use it in any of my examples but
contact is how you share kind of data
between any resolver so that context is
a great use case for things like
authentication or you know however you
want to do that kind of stuff basically
anything that you think makes sense to
share between each of these resolvers
you'd want to put that in context and it
would be exposed to these resolvers
under that third argument so next now
our first argument is a little more
interesting when we resolve a user and
on this separate field we already have a
user at this point so it'll basically
resolve a user and then it'll go and get
things that it doesn't have so for
instance to resolve this user manager
will call this for every user that we
receive will call this manager API if
the graph QL query specified that this
manager be included and so the first
argument is actually the value in JSON
of the user I requested so this user
will have a user ID username user dot
title whatever I need to actually make
that separate request so this is
actually a really really just awesome
way to reduce round-robin requests so if
I want a manager always my requester
user this is how you can do that in
graphic UL via this concept of resolvers
and so wiring it all up it's pretty easy
like I said we're using graph QL tools
which is a library from Apollo open
source type depths is basically your
schema as a string it's the previous
example of what we were showing
resolvers is that javascript object each
key a function that resolves to a
promise or something that matches the
shape of what I'm the type and then our
schema which we can use and something
like Express graph QL that we can
actually use this schema is created with
this function make executive or schema
so I'll show this in a little more depth
during the live coding session so
hopefully not too overwhelming I think
it's kind of cool because basically we
just resolved to restful endpoints doing
something that was normally a little bit
more challenging and like ten minutes of
explaining it and so this kind of I
think shows the kind of the power of
graph QL and in particular resolvers are
a key aspect of understanding how graph
QL can be so it can be so transformative
if I haven't explained explain this well
enough so let's basically say that when
I'm requesting a user you know and I
want to display it on this view if I
were to use the traditional rest
approach I would need to display this
user kick off another request and then I
would get the manager at some point in
the future with this approach with graph
QL I come across exactly what I need for
this specific view and get both with one
request and if my needs change down the
road I tonight I don't want a manager I
don't need to modify my rest go over my
you know my back-end code I can just do
so with my graph QL query so you know
this is Nebraska Jaso I'm definitely
gonna have a Java Script focus but graph
QL is background agnostic so pretty much
bring your own back-end net Erlang go
groovy Java cetera et cetera
if you're not a Java Script shop if you
are a groovy shop and your back-end is
written in groovy there are references
invitations that let you use graph QL on
your server in each of these languages
and probably more that argument on this
slide so basically you don't have to die
you know totally dive in to the node.js
ecosystem there are implementations in
other languages
so if you're like I said if your team is
you know insert X language here don't
rule out graph QL because you think it's
just no or javascript-based so I've kind
of I think explained some of the
problems that solves you know queering
is a subset of data giving getting the
user data from multiple endpoints but in
one request without hitting at XY and z
endpoints and then also just you know a
pretty clean api it also solves other
problems so john grater of jquery says
hahaha back to Ella's totally so you
decided to use a no sequel database and
now you want reasonable queries back
here's a graph QL and so basically the
heart of I think the appeal of graph QL
that's letting me as a front-end
developer is basically here is a super
slick intuitive way that I can make this
data understandable and really easy to
query against so regardless of whatever
you know insert hot back-end technique
of the day like mango or DynamoDB or you
know insert whatever here you can put
graph QL that's kind of a front-end to
that data and make it more easily
consumable by your developers or by your
users it's also documentation so that
graph QL schema that we were talking
about earlier is actually really easy to
be wired up to a tool called graph eql
or graphical I don't really know it's
one of the other but basically this is a
react app that you can get really easily
with some of the middlewares the one I
used here is for express literally I set
true on a JavaScript object and I get
this for free and I basically get a
playground where I can hit my actual
graph QL API and on the left you get
like an auto completing IDE I'll show
this more in depth at the end and then
you can actually hit the API and then on
the right you have your schema so when I
request posts I know that post accept
start limit and then returned to posts
like I get a really good understanding
of my data contract and I can also call
it directly so of course anyone familiar
with like swagger or anything like that
has seen something kind of like
this but I didn't write any code besides
that type to get this to work this just
worked out of the box I think that's
pretty sweet
alright so I'm browsing Twitter the
other day and oh my god kind of tweeted
something what is this so I click it and
I see that it has 28 thousand retweets
and 121,000 mics and person X Y & Z
liked it and it shows their avatars and
then I want to go and read the comments
and so I load all these comments and so
basically um I don't think leaders API
actually works this way this is just for
purposes of demonstration so to make to
get that first timeline I can call this
API tweets and in every turn basically
an array of all my tweets without all
the data I requested basically just the
minimal subset of what I need for my
current view next to get more detail to
get those user avatars and you know
stuff like that I make a request for
this this particular tweet resource and
then finally to get the whole
conversation I make a third request and
so what we've really introduced is the
concept of like waterfall requests we
make one initial request and then to get
more detail drilled down we make
separate other requests and you know for
anyone who cares about page speed and
performance and you know all that kind
of stuff this is not great Waterfall
requests make the client harder to kind
of understand when you're actually
writing it and they of course make
performance suffer so graph QL can
resolve each of these as requested and
kind of avoid some of this waterfall
giving the client just the minimum
subset of data and needs to render this
particular page so we have any pipe in
example this is one percent made up API
but pretend is Twitter and timeline is
basically going to return an array of
tweets the tweet has an ID a tweet has a
body a tweet has number of likes number
of retweets and to kind of like hydrate
and to give my page kind of like a
speedy performant feel I can use I can
get the conversation for each of these
tweets so I'm just grabbing the first
twenty really that's probably
unrealistic I probably want like four or
five or something and then I can deeply
get you know this this conversation ID
the conversation body you know what the
content of this is likes retweets I
forgot authors but you know authors
would go there too and so basically we
can call this we get back our ate up
tweets and we get back the minimum
subset of data we need to render this
particular page while also doing so
performant Li and if we click on a tweet
we can then you know use our first five
10 conversations or whatever and then
give more as they scroll down the page
so this makes graph QL reduce this
waterfall requests and render this page
performant Li using exactly what I need
to hydrate this page so let's come back
to this question is it a rest killer I
know I said I wasn't gonna say it is so
I won't no no I do not think graphic QL
is a rest killer I think it's kind of
contradictory to say that something is
killing something when it makes it
better in my opinion putting a graph QL
layer in front of your breast full API
is one of the best ways you can make
your API is better documented more
easily queryable and get some of the
benefits we talked about like better
client side speed easier queries easier
understanding all from the client so no
I do think that graph QL is novel so
basically if you're a breast person I
hope you don't think that graph QL is
stealing your jobs because it's not at
all so let's talk about integration how
do we actually integrate I've kind of
showed this to some extent the example I
gave was like a restful back-end and so
basically it's gonna be from that
context how I kind of constructed the
integration argument so number one
advice is layer the graph QL API in
front of your resisting REST API s so if
you already have a great rest api that
you really like works really well you
don't need to you know go whole hog and
migrate over to graph QL you can do it
by just putting a graph to L layer and
using the resolvers approach that I
showed earlier and I think this will be
a lot better for reasons like you can
keep your business logic intact I've
seen some pretty nasty you know
controller functions that are you know
doing XYZ and the other thing don't you
don't need to refactor those to use
graph QL you can keep those as is you
know they're working somehow
hopefully they're tested but but
basically by using this approach I just
craft qlae or in front you you can do
this more gradually and my other advice
is to adopt graph QL gradually you don't
need to have you know a month or two
months or whatever to say hey we're
gonna supposed to graph QL API and it's
going to do everything our REST API does
it's going to hit every single restful
endpoint that's not a lot what you have
to do I mean you can expose just one two
or three api's make your back-end
service which could be like monolithic
or whatever make it more easily
queryable more easily consumable while
getting some of the benefits of graph QL
that we've that I've talked about so
there are there are tools that I think
make this a little bit easier Apollo
it's a really big one
Apollo has a number of open-source
libraries that graph QL tools library I
was referring to is from Apollo it's
open source they also have kind of like
a service offering and so the one I've
seen that seems kind of enticing is they
have a service offering that'll kind of
profile your graphic you all queries
it'll do really slick caching I'll be
resisting api's and it'll give you a
really good blogging as well so Apollo
is like a really big hitter in this
graph QL space graph cool is another big
hitter I'm not as familiar with graph
cool so if anyone after has used graph
cool and wants to say yay or nay let me
know
but basically graphical is doing similar
things to Apollo in this space they're
kind of offering graph QL as a service
so take given your existing API your
justing back-end we can wire this up
will give you kind of like a server list
graph QL API and you can pretty quickly
hit the ground running using graph cool
so definitely if you're interested in
this space check out both of these tools
and their offerings they're pretty great
so basically my advice you know let's
say you have an API right now and you
have a slash user and a slash user ID
what I would do is at the same URL or at
least like a similar URL expose a slash
graph to L endpoint that is your graphic
ul API and begin by just migrating two
of your kind of like simpler ones two of
them ones that are you
understood that have a good data model
between what you call on what you get
and then start it integrating graph QL
using this approach using gradual using
the gradual approach just putting a
layer in front of your existing restful
back-end so this talk I did want to talk
a little bit about client-side
integration and I wanted it to be mostly
back in server-side focus but some of
the big benefits we're talking about are
in the client-side integration so I
think it's at least worth mentioning
some of the client-side libraries and
techniques first it is a Apollo so just
like in the backend integration Apollo
has a number of really really great
client-side offerings they're big one is
called Apollo client and they also have
a number of kind of like wrappers of
Apollo client that lets you work with
Apollo with view with react with angular
like I even saw polymer I'm sure there's
a you know framework agnostic solution
as well and basically it lets you hit
the ground running pretty quick and
easily wrapping up this graph QL API and
giving you some other niceties so let's
take a look at apollo boost so apollo
boost came out i don't know in last six
months at least probably no sooner than
that and it's a it's a react library so
hopefully at least some people are in a
orange didn't react and basically what
it what it kind of advertises as is is
like a really simple like 10 15 minute
way you can begin integrating graph QL
into your client and so it exposes a
number of like really helpful things
like react components as well as this
import gql so gql is from graph QL tag
another library and basically what it
does is you can write your graph QL
queries as a string and it'll convert it
to an abstract syntax tree and this tree
can be passed to this react component so
basically this is saying query movie is
gonna be the movie I asked for I don't
want to get to react specific here but
basically this is a function it's invoke
a
at various kind of like sages in the
life cycle so when it's loading you can
display a loading screen when is in an
air State you can just play an air state
and
finally when it actually does resolve
the data hopefully all things going well
you can return the actual movie based on
that graph QL query so graph cool
another similar story I have not used it
but I know people really like it and
they offer some client-side options in
this space though something a trend here
yeah so like I said those are the two
big offerings in both kind of back-end
and client-side graph QL as well as some
of the stuff that Facebook puts out like
their vacuole breakfast supplementation
so if you're just sitting in this space
be it from a front-end or back-end
perspective check out Apollo checkout
graph cool they can both do some really
nice things for your API of course you
know people get kind of like library
phobic and you know I don't need this
library like so you can also use fetch
you know just the vanilla fetch client
graph QL the way it actually works is it
exposed as a post endpoint so you can
send headers and then you can send your
query as a JSON body and this will work
just the same as the previous example
but you're not getting you know the
niceties of well what how do I handle an
air State how do I handle data state how
do I handle loading state evening out
you're getting all that for free that's
kind of wiring that up for you of course
if your API authenticated it's gonna get
harder and harder to kind of maintain
this and so basically I would urge you
to consider one of the libraries but if
you're the type who wants to roll your
own that works just fine Oracle is
formidable if you are yeah that's a
great picture if you're in the react
space Oracle is kind of advertises
itself as like a public client but
strictly for like react so it's react
optimized supposed to get you up and
running really quickly and offers some
like react components that do similar
things to Apollo boost woo so demos that
was me right now Jordan Peele so what
I'm going to do is I did a couple things
so I wrote a rest endpoint with
expressed and then hosted it with now
and I'll going to go into some detail
and basically
do is kind of what this whole talk has
been about I want to take this rest API
and I want to enhance it with graph QL
so I have a separate graph QL API that I
have like a really basic structure
around and we can begin by integrating
queries and mutations and then finally
I'm gonna do a long time oh I have
plenty of time okay
I'll also show the speaker sign up which
so as Nick was referring to earlier we
have Nebraska je s has a github repo
where you can open up an issue and you
can kind of submit a proposal for the
next Nebraska je s talk it could be for
yourself to be for someone else or
cetera I don't think lot of people know
about it so I wanted to kind of put a UI
around it and you can do things like add
a proposal add reactions etc etc so
first though let's start with the live
coding so this is just a repo this is a
simple Express app nothing major here so
simple credit API I can get posts I can
add a post I can delete a post I can
update a post cetera et cetera we have a
kind of secondary layer kind of
analogous to the user manager approach
of by default we don't get comments with
the post so it'd be nice when we request
a post to not round-robin and to get
those comments along for the ride where
we want them so yeah all this open
source obviously so come take a look at
this after if you're interested but we
can actually get started
how's that font size good okay so I have
this graph QL back-end this graph QL
back-end is just an expressed node app
and it's using a couple libraries using
Express it's using Express graph QL
which is a middleware that les says give
this schema listen we're going to be
creating and kind of create a graph QL
endpoint and also for free lets us use
that graph eql practical kind of like UI
and it does this with you know two lines
of code so this is kind of cool
basically when we go to our API wherever
it's hosted we can do /ql
and we'll see the graphical UI so we
also have the schema and here I'm using
graph QL tools so the first thing I want
to do is I want to install these two
things how's the font on that I'm gonna
go a little bigger all right so I like
to use yarn but you can just as easily
install your dependencies with NPM so
I'm gonna solve both of these all right
now we're getting closer to going so
this schema the schema is just in es2015
template literal it's a string with
multi lines and so everything I can put
in here what stuff we talked about so I
can have a post and so basically what
you need to ask yourself here is what is
a post you know what is insert X and my
existing restful back-end and so like I
said most people put kind of like a
swagger endpoint I didn't do that you
know I don't really need to make this
super enterprise-e but uh so basically I
use this library called yup and when I
update or add a post I call this
basically validator function and here is
a pretty good indication of what a post
is it's a title as an author
it's a publish date and then it's a body
ID is optional because when you're
creating a post you don't know the idea
that IDs created for you so I can copy
this over make these all strings to
begin with them is not knowable because
a post is defined if these you know
minimum subsets of attributes ID has an
ID they know the graph QL ISM and so now
we have our first type so to actually
use this we need to create a query so
again let's kind of similar to previous
samples I showed type query and then
every kind of like think of a key value
is kind of like a function it's a
resolver that resolves to something so
to get a post I'm gonna start with kind
of easier approach I'm just going to get
a single post
and to get a post what I need is an ID
so I'm requesting an ID and a post this
query this resolver will always we
always return something of post but
that's not actually true if I query for
ABCD and that is not as this in my
database I'm gonna get a null post so I
need to make this nullable finally we
have the schema and so the schema is
composed of a type of query and if
needed a type of mutation so I can give
it this I can comment I can get rid of
that to do and let's see our first pfaff
ql api suite they worked so it's all
over the host 4,000 doesn't matter okay
so this is this is graph eql and so it's
basically like an IDE kind of in the
browser so I can query for a post I can
give it an ID and you can see it's out
of its Auto completing for me so ID
ideas whatever one two three four and
then when I get a post when I query for
a post I know I have a post so I can
request my what I want when I want to
display this post so I want to display
the author I want to display the body
I'll grab the ID and then the publish
date so I can run this I don't get back
null and that makes perfect sense
because I haven't wired it up yet I've
only exposed the schema I haven't
resolved any of these fields so much of
anything so let's close this let's go
back and let's start wiring up these
resolvers so like I said earlier
basically any type is a top-level key
for those resolvers so to get a post I
want to wire this up as query top-level
query and then post and so like I said
each resolver is a function and so this
needs to
take this route don't need it args I do
need
so this args will be an object with an
IB of whatever type of type ID and then
if I wanted to have this be
authenticated or whatever I would
probably use this third argument context
to send that along for the ride to my
restful endpoint so I am using a few api
or a few libraries here Axios kinda like
fetch just an HTTP client for node it's
a little it does things a little more
automatically for me than fetch so I
like it
config as a library where I can just
external eyes in JSON these different
config files so this is actually the API
that I'm hitting and then query string
it just basically says given an object
converges to a query string parameter so
first thing we want is we have these
args we have this ID so this is an
object that has basically this and I'm
using destructuring here I don't have to
so I can just go this way if I want to
get the query string parameters I need
to call keep up query string dot
stringify args and so basically what
this will do I jump the gun that is for
the next section I want a URL so the URL
is just going to be AC URL right slash
host slash card ID so a typical restful
request and every resolver needs to
return a promise or the actual value I'm
requesting so I can do Axios URL and
then axe neocon wraps this promise for
me so I can just do response data so now
we can run this again and let's see what
we get here
let's talk about that no wait I don't
think it resolved yet
okay so requests fail the status status
code for tonight that makes sense
I'm not clearing for an actual post yet
so post is just gonna get all the posts
so that I can then use this ID until
here you can see what a post is title
author ID published body can use this
and now we see our rest back-end
resolved with the actual data when I
request this post obviously I can get
rid of any single thing here and you
know it'll still resolve to the shape of
what I'm requesting so my query drives
my output so one of the appeals of what
I was talking about is kind of resolving
those round-robin requests so when I
want a post I don't necessarily want to
make a second HTTP request to get that
list of comments and so there's a
RESTful API that I exposed in my breast
back-end that basically returns comments
for a post so to actually to kind of
give a hint to graph QL of what a
comment is I need to use a comment I got
lazy and my rest back-end and so I did
not add a an API to add comments so I
need a look in my head database which is
just JSON and I can get a pretty good
idea of what everything is so again same
type of thing here making these all non
nullable I have a unique ID for each of
these so I'll use the graph or I'll use
the graph to ID type and now when I
request a post I also want to optionally
request all the comments for this post
so I can wire this up and so basically
I'm saying this is a resolver and this
resolver might have optional arguments
so for comments I might want to limit to
you know say the first five comments I
also might want to start at you know
this number so for instance if I hydrate
Paige with the first five comments when
I want to load the rest I don't want to
start at zero and request ten I want to
start at five and request the next five
so this is a way I can do these two can
do that both of these are knowable which
means I can call this without these
arguments and it'll basically give me
the entire contents of my comments API
and so comments returns an array not
nullable of type comment so again it
needs to return either an empty array or
an array that if it does have contents
each of which is a comment so this is
the kind of slightly more complicated
part I was talking about earlier so
basically each type and is a key so this
is post and I want to resolve this
comments field so comments the very
first argument when graph QL resolves
these it resolves the kind of base level
thing first so at the time this resolver
function is run I already have my post
so the very first argument is post the
next is this kind of optional args
so if Argos was supplied if arguments
were supports applied to this function
it would be limit of type number and or
start of type number of type int don't
me to use context here here's where I
was string of firing earlier so params
qsr stringify all right so basically
this will create the structure if args
is defined like lemonade equals 10 and
start equals 10 so I can pass that as a
query string directly onto my restful
back-end right and so because I have a
post at the time this is resolved I can
do Axios I need to do a URL so the path
to this is my face URL slash post slash
post that ID and then slash comments of
course I want to bring my friends params
along for the ride so that I actually
get back what I expect the number of
things I respect I expect and we can
make this request this is a promise and
the response is on response that data
this this API returns
a JSON object the only key and it is
comments which is an array so to get
back the actual shape the graph QL
expects I just need to call this
comments I can save this
I can rerun all right so if I query this
I could if I logged this is not calling
comments at all
there's no second requests it's not even
resolving that because I haven't
requested it the first time I do
oops all right I'm using the
autocomplete let's say to begin with I
just want to get everything a comment
has an ID it has it published it has an
author as a body and I want all of those
things I can run this and I get back my
entire array of comments this is just
one graph QL query know you know
client-side logic to fetch this and the
other thing is doing it and handling at
the background level for me
conditionally when I asked for it so
this right now is kind of I'm not
passing any arguments because both of
those arguments were optional let's say
I only want one comment works just fine
I get back to my one comment of course I
can jump this up and I get back multiple
so that's kind of how you begin wiring
up queries I figured I can show me a
mutation - it's pretty simple so a
mutation is just like query it's a root
level type all whatever you want and I'm
gonna call mutation and it's going to be
a function that creates a post and so a
post as in this mutation is slightly
different than a post a type of post I
basically don't know the ID when I add a
post so basically I can call this input
post input input basically is something
that is passed to a mutation and I want
everything besides ID and ID will be
created for me right so that is the
mutation
takes input of post input and it'll
always return a non malleable post I
need to add this as a mutation and I
need to actually create the resolver so
root level mutation
it's called create post mutations and
queries because they're kind of like
already at the base level don't really
have anything provided at that first
argument it does have the second
argument is actually going to be input
so I want to pluck and put off of that
javascript object I can start setting up
my URL so it's going to be base URL
posts I'm returning a promise
Axios dot post URL and response response
data
second argument to Axios dot post is
basically the JavaScript object and I'm
Jason I'm sending on to the server so
that is input and let's try this out so
the syntax can change a little bit it's
going to be a mutation I'm going to be
trading a post I can already see the IDS
handling things for me and a post input
is composed of title author published
body so title hello from Nebraska typing
this hard offer me the published is just
today so there whoops published is 0 5 0
1 2018 and then the body is back ul is
sweet in my opinion and I think I did
when I run this I get back oh I'm just
needed selections I get back this ID I
only requested idea actually requested
nothing at all
that for me but basically when I create
a post I get back a post so now I can go
back to this
I can query based on this post I just
created ID it'll be the ID I passing
body author title published and I can
pull this back this like I said is using
a restful back end so my business logic
stays intact
you know I sent like a JavaScript date
kind of and this gave me back an ISO
string so it handles that serialization
layer for me obviously a super simple
example you know you could be touching
35 different systems and doing all this
stuff when you create a mutation so yeah
I could cut the biz logic intact and I
exposed a graph QL API with queries and
mutations so that was that demo I
actually kind of have another one so
like I said I think we have an awesome
community here and I hope people are
interested in passionate about it as I
am so I wanted to create something to
kind of give back so basically this is a
site it's currently hosted on notify
maybe someday if people like it we can
get a actual root level domain in front
of it so basically a speaker sign up
that net Lefou com
this is using github graph to LAPI and a
tool called Gatsby so what's kind of
cool is that I can log out I can turn
off let's go away I can turn off
JavaScript and this page still works as
statically generated react code so
anything you know without JavaScript I
can't actually do much kind of like
read-only mode but it's still kind of
cool I can enable JavaScript and so I'm
not currently logged in if I want to log
in basically what I went with is kind of
do something that requires a login so if
I want if I'm really passionate about
touch script I'm gonna add this tada
emoji
how many reaction cars log me in login
sure okay so normally there'd be a login
screen I'm already logged in before so
that you know did not didn't show up but
so now I'm logged in until now basically
what I have is I have a application
by default has these posts and then from
this point I can then hydrate with SQL
so I'm using Apollo client actually
apollo boost and I can add reactions
I love typescript no one gave my reason
post and update so jumbo observables fan
love them you know etc etc graph QL I
like it
I think heart maybe I don't like it
maybe you you know whatever cetera etc
so obviously I can get rid of all these
and they go away we're just like github
you can also check out previous
proposals you can see my test post
please ignore we can upload that one
excetera what I think web component was
done so was previously given so that's a
close proposal if I want to add one test
post please ignore again you can use
emojis here they'll show up in the other
view a hundred waves okay and we can
send this this is actually not using
graph QL so github is kind of using my
approach of adopt things gradually so
the for some reason there's no mutation
for trading and issue invitation for
adding a reaction
cuz that's important but I can't
actually so this is just using fetch to
hit the github the old version of their
API I can send this we got it thanks go
back
test test post please ignore again
emojis okay hand is not an emoji I guess
yada yada obviously we can go to this
repo you can see it I can add a reaction
we fresh there it is so it all works out
which is kind of cool
so yeah come check this page out maybe
Nebraska doors can tweet it out if it's
worthwhile I can show some of the code I
think we have like five minutes or so
every bad but I don't people understand
seeing the client-side code yeah No okay
I'm gonna show so this is like I said a
Gatsby application
Gatsby is pretty awesome it's a static
site generator where you can write your
routes each component each of you and
react and I'm using Apollo to kind of
hydrate this space client so I have to
set up a number of things this Apollo
client is the main way I communicate
with Gibbs API it doesn't really do
anything until I authenticate and then
it uses your authentication token you
get back from github to you know set on
this Apollo client so github it has a
graphical API and it's using that
context argument that I was referring to
earlier so it's bringing on my
authorization headers along for the ride
code itself so github has a really good
graph QL Explorer so basically you get
kind of like a graph eql interface where
you can actually query stuff is how I
wrote all of this so I have this graph
QL folder this is the query that's
generating pretty much all of this
this view is open proposals and close
proposals generated with this graph QL
query so my queries called get all
issues this requires an owner a name the
at the actual query and get-ups API is
called repository and a repository
basically has a number of fields I'm
only caring about issues so I get the
last 50 I order by so-and-so and then
I'm getting all of these I'm only
getting the first 10 reactions so if we
had 20 reactions you're only gonna see
ten of them
sorry and yeah this is how that works
mutations a little bit uglier so this is
just a dynamic it's the function
scenario function so it's mutation type
is either add or remove so mutation add
reaction mutation remove reaction and
it's calling the necessary github draft
ul API so yeah that is the demos and all
of these are available this slide deck
is listed I graph QL just on shout comm
check out some of these links I'll tweet
stuff out
after this and thank you for listening
really appreciate it everyone coming out
on this crappy day any questions you
could so you just submit and a proposal
you would say this is for someone so and
no so I usually get up API so whatever
your user you got that nicka does is
what the issue will be opened up as yeah
and that's another point like you don't
have to give to talk yourself you can
just have a good idea and you're like
someone should talk about this sometime
yeah so yeah do that
so github didn't have the create issue
graph QL API so actually all it is is
I'm just I'm using fetch and basically
where is it
so if I'm authentic ated I'll hit this
REST API from github and then with you
know specified data so I actually can't
do anything about that I would need
github to open up permutation that adds
that functionality
no I yeah I wish it works that way but
basically you're kind of at the same way
of like if if this rest back-end didn't
have insert you know API here like I
would kind of I can't read you anything
so this is basically v3 up yet hubs API
the kind of cool thing is are really
cool actually kind of sucks is so
because this graph QL query doesn't
really so that issues query it doesn't
really know when stuff happens when I'm
doing it locally I need to call this
client dot resets store so this is
something I get from Apollo and
basically I'm saying hey I know that
you'll have new data go and request it
and so you can do some other things you
can actually do polling so every 5
seconds we
freshest view I didn't do this also some
graphic ul API is I haven't looked at
this at all
but you can do subscriptions so
basically kind of like long-running
polls like you know push and pop type
stuff like push to this API and then let
the consumer know that something new
happened you can do all that with
graphic UL but I'm not an expert on that
stuff I'm a particular part or anything
any other questions yeah yeah so in
making this demo you know it sounds
pretty like sunshine and rainbows to say
hey for every comment go make this
request and the way I was originally
doing it I didn't I wasn't aware of
these um those like other so like when I
get a post I'm requesting comments what
I was actually doing is I was
automatically grabbing all comments and
that initial post resolver instead of
using the actual user resolver and so
basically every request to of posts was
calling the comments API ten times so it
was just super slow so basically just be
aware of how those resolvers are
actually firing your api is gonna kind
of be slow if you have like thirty
resolvers each grabbing some other
particular piece so if you can kind of
structure your rest api to avoid those
separate requests that'll just lead to
better performance also I didn't really
say this but obviously like a restful
back-end is kind of like a middleman if
you can you know down the road if you
think Rock QL is awesome and you want to
get rid of your best flow back in if you
directly call whatever your muscle back
end is like modifying be it a bicycle
database or MongoDB database or you know
whatever you can use those resolvers to
type that directly rather than hitting
the restful endpoint so turning into
printer performance issues that's
probably depending on how severe they
are that could certainly be an option is
um check that out eventually
since 2012 I believe yeah they uh they
started probably on the newsfeed
I actually don't know what they started
on and yeah they've been using it I
think in production since 2012 and I
think they open sourced it and I was
like 2015 maybe seen that so relatively
long ago and as far as you know
client-side technologies go yeah
hopefully yours github Facebook
I think Pinterest there are a number
like pretty big sites who are using
graph QL in production absolutely I'm
glad you asked that
so Gatsby is how I learned it back to
you well gas feed taught me the query
layer and Gatsby use that graphi I think
you L good time so yeah I don't really
touch the actual data like I'm not
really creating data and Gatsby I'm more
like clearing it but Gatsby is what
taught me to do clearing with graph QL
to see those explore and to really kind
of understand the things I can do with
back you well so obviously so this is a
speaker signup running locally I have it
oh I shouldn't oh yeah
so this is not hitting abrasca J yes
luckily is hitting my just some random
rebelling picked of my own stuff and the
way Gatsby works as they expose their
graph QL API at this and then I can get
this really good so I can see basically
all the sites that make up the speaker
signup and without really knowing much
about the underlying data just I kind of
just fiddled that together I can see
that there's a 404 page there's all of
these proposals are to show that
obviously can click on all these two and
you know go look at stuff more in depth
but um so yeah Gatsby is what got me to
understand and to really appreciate
craft well and how it actually works
so Gatsby has this concept of source
plugins and so I actually wrote Gatsby
source github and it lets me basically
use this query to get all issues and to
like make that queryable via that local
site and you know the production side
too so basically it'll call github graph
QL API make those nodes queryable via
Gatsby and then I can query them to
create the pages so the actual query is
yeah basically here and this is used
it'll work without JavaScript that was
kind of cool it'll create a static HTML
for me so sorry second question I'll
explain the first one so github is
hosting crappy QL this is how I learned
it they also have API Doc's but this
this to me is I guess I'm not the
biggest user of swagger so you might
know more stuff than I do but this is
really what I want I can go in and look
and see all the available queries I can
see the arguments for those queries so
for instance I can get a github license
I can get getup code of conduct I can
get a node organization and then
repository is actually what I'm using so
I
can see here at a glance the repository
has an owner it has a name and then I
can run this query eventually when I
look at all this and I get my
autocomplete for it like for free oh oh
I didn't use variables is yes and so
this is this is the exact data on
getting client-side and under breath and
that speaker sign up Pablo is
technically I don't know I think I kind
of probably is kind of my graph cool is
supposed to do and plus William some of
Apollo's offerings basically they're
like generate the graph QL API for you
given some data but I don't have a ton
of experience and doing it that way I've
always just written it but it's a good
question I don't know the answer that
any other questions I got you out of
here at 7 minutes early so thank you
everyone
[Applause]